you've got fat
the things i do for love
one word and i hit you again i'm telling
mother
children don't need to hear your filth
can the treasury
bear such expense it's empty your grace
so get more
what did i buy you for to make me sad
i've been sitting here for days start
the damn
joust before i piss myself it's made too
small your grace it won't go
your mother was a dumb [__] with a fat
ass did you know that
you heard the hand the king's too fat
for his armor go find the breastplate
stretcher
sigil a lion words lannister always
his debt no a common saying but not
their official motto
the eerie they say it's impregnable
give me ten good men and some climbing
spikes i'll impregnate the [__]
the [__] is pregnant do you think honor
keeps them in line
do you think it's honor that's keeping
the peace it's fear
fear and blood our marriage
[Laughter]
and there is only one thing we say to
death
not today so the lion does concern
himself with the opinions no that's not
an opinion it's a fact
give me something for the pain and let
me die
do you have a shred of honor
here boy melted down and added to the
others
cut his throat stop
wait i've changed my mind let him go
not really relevance then is it you know
nothing
jon snow where are my dragons
tyrion will do us his bid as will you
what do you mean we'll marry solaris
[Music]
i understand that if any more words come
pouring out your
mouth i'm gonna have to eat every
[__] chicken in this room
you're going to do all seven other
[__] father
lady aaron died three days ago
[Laughter]
[Applause]
the future is [__]
just like the past
you can smell the [__] from five miles
away
shame shame
shame shame watch is ended
[Music]
a lannister always don't say it don't
[__] say it
we have enough provisions for two years
i make jokes
it appears the queen mother doesn't wish
to attend her own trial
forgive my sister what she lacks in
diplomacy
shut up dear
it's a pretty song i've never heard it
before it's a new one
are you hungry a finger in the bomb
your lord of winterfell now i can never
be lord of winterfell
i can never be lord of anything rickon
dickon
i am lord protector of the veil and i
command you to escort me safely back to
the eerie
i think not
look at you you're a man
almost
i wanted those elephants
who is the first someone taller
that's how i got so strong
giant's milk
dracaris
theon
a good man thank you
i don't really want any more
mostly i live in the past people get
bloody murdered
they stay that way not this one
i told you i don't want it it doesn't
matter what you want
you are my queen i don't know what else
i can see
[Music]
while danny kind of forgot about the
iron fleet and euron's forces
they certainly haven't forgotten about
her and they're just waiting for her to
come back
and who has a better story than brand
the broken
why do you think i came all this way
you